i'd rather have four or five films under
my belt in five years than talking about
making one that's just me personally
when you were making movies with charlie
sheen at that time how much did it cost
to make them and how much were the
distributors paying you for the movies
back when we were doing those um
we were an independent company that that
kind of decided to do its own content
it's kind of the early
working with some of the majors but
getting a real taste of independent
filmmaking
um we were really in a fortune fortunate
situation because charlie was a movie
star you know he had just come off
things like terminal velocity and shadow
conspiracy and
you know the arrival and and his
incredible catalog of work
and so we we had the avi learners
coming to us saying
we'll we'll give you up to 10 to 12
million to go make a movie
and so
they weren't distributors that were
buying them they were people like avi
that obviously would you know smart
businessman he would he would cast it
with real players and go sell it at can
or afm before we even shot a foot of
film i remember we went to cannes
um for the 50th anniversary and they put
us up at the hotel do cop
and um we had a press conference and it
was mock artwork of the film with
charlie sheen mark de coskos
um joe lando martin sheen
and
you know they pre-sold that thing
globally i'm sure for a lot more than
they gave us to make it the film did
very well
miramax dimension actually ended up
picking it up
and they made some good tv deals on it
and
we made the film for 12. we actually
made it for nine because we shot it in
arizona at the time they at the time had
a 30
rebate so we got i think 3 million back
in actual cash rebate wasn't tax
incentives it was cash rebate
and
that's how movies used to be made
especially in such a huge home video
market that was the height of
blockbuster and you know
hollywood video and all those great you
know brick and mortar mod paw stores
were just they
they were printing money because of the
home video market and dvds coming out
blu-ray hadn't hit yet so they were
giving us a lot of money you know we
were making some of these indie films
for eight to 12 million
those were good times those were really
good times
how much easier was it to make movies in
the 90s
well
i don't know if it was easier um
[Music]
there when we were making them you know
the budgets were big we were able to
kick out a couple a year um
and again the home video market was so
was so big you know you were able to get
territories to put up a lot of money
around the globe for the home video
market tv rights foreign theatrical you
know things have changed substantially
um i find it easier to make movies now
because we're able to make movies for a
lot less i mean we're shooting all those
movies on panavision 35 millimeter
cameras you know that camera package to
rent that film to to buy and process and
tell us any and convert to video you
know digital format so you can cut it on
your avids which back then cost 180 000
you know it movies were expensive back
then
uh we weren't making them for cheap
um it's just you know
and we were doing independent films and
you know i cringe today when i hear
about independent movies that are like
five million dollars i think that's no
indy you know five million dollars in
today's economy be great that the toys
that we have that we can make movies for
but back then we were doing the indies
for you know eight to 12 million
what should a filmmaker use to determine
a budget whatever he can get
and i mean that i i'm a big proponent
of what's your budget who cares i
you know so many of us
it's it's about a budget you know you
can get it broken down six ways till
sunday ten different line producers
break it down budget it you can use all
your different pay scales with the
unions and whatnot
that's all that's all going to be black
and white
but at the end of the day what's
stopping you from getting the movie made
so for me
i
don't think about
what a budget has to be i think about i
always put my investor first i always
think what's going to put he or she at
the lowest risk
how do we execute this to the best of
our ability so we can out kick our punt
coverage we can now punch our weight
class puts put it all on the screen and
wow people for a fraction of what people
think we actually made it for that's
just my mentality doesn't mean it's
right for everybody so when i look at a
project
when an investor calls me and says we're
ready to go or i call them and say i'm
ready to go what's your comfort level
for the next season and they tell me um
i say okay this is how much we have what
can we do with this
i i kind of go into it bass backwards
and i i just i
i watch filmmakers
time and time again not get movies made
because they've set some some budget in
their mind and unless you're being given
the money by a studio or a network who
is really governing that that's what the
budget has to be
um
you know my father
tried for four years to get desperate
passage made he had a million dollar
budget back in 1980
well it started in 82. so a million
dollars was a lot of money back then
finally in
1985-86 he got 25 grand to go make the
movie that was you know cutting really
short to the chase on this story
and
my my mother my father and i with a
couple of tight filmmaker friends we we
huddled together and figured out how we
were going to do it and i don't think
the film would have been at all
different if we had had the million
versus the 25.
i don't think a frame of the film would
have been any different
and the success that that film had it
taught me how to make movies for nothing
and you know what it launched
you know ultimately gridiron gang and a
lot of you know seven other movies of
the week that collectively did very well
that all came from a 25 000 let's do
this from a million dollar budget so for
me
i always tell a filmmaker
what do you have access to
what are your means if you're going to
write the check yourself
what can you afford how can you do this
really break it down let's not think
about putting all the money in your
pocket let's think about building
content are you going to be able to own
the library when it's all said and done
it's become a valuable asset to you 20
years from now
and i think it just you know in most of
the
the the talks that we give with with
producers and webinars it's it's
the main reason people are not making
their content is because they can't
raise the money that they've this
self-imposed budget
and i just think sometimes if they they
really
really learn the craft of of how to get
things done
and not
chins out on what your ultimate vision
is i mean it's not about cheapening out
or chinsing out okay sure you're not
going to get george clooney
on a 500 000 budget versus a 50 million
dollar budget but
is you trying to get that 50 million
dollars going to be 10 years from now
you're talking about getting that movie
made still or have you moved on to five
other movies you still haven't made and
and for me it's about
getting excited about making a project
and doing everything you can to get it
done and okay this is what we have to do
it we're getting it done for this let's
go and that's probably one reason that i
that i have the career i have where it's
it's not about the budget and what it
has to be it's this is what we can do
our next project for let's create this
content for this budget
and and every project you do is going to
build you to another level whether it's
dollars or actor level or distribution
or whatever you have to look at you know
this this industry
we we hear about the success stories but
for for most of us it's truly a marathon
it's not a sprint and you have to look
long-term it's like you know when you
put money into a cd or an ira it's
long-term growth and you have to look at
this career like that because
having a script you're running around
town with trying to raise 10 15 20
million dollars on and not getting it
done does not get anything done
but if you're able to get
similar content or even that that
passion project to yours done for the
money that you really can get or or
raise
and you get it done it's just going to
build and build and build to get to
where you ultimately want to go and
personally i'd rather have four or five
films under my belt in five years than
talking about making one that's just me
personally
you know
just that's my advice to filmmakers is
really think about what you can do
something for
and where is this budget coming from
because if the content is good and the
cast is respectable enough to get
eyeballs
you're you're going to have you know
hopefully some success with it you're
going to move it
and just because the budget's high does
not guarantee success it doesn't
guarantee distribution there's a lot of
very expensive movies that are sitting
in cans right now that have been done
for years with a-list stars that have
never seen the light of day
you know
and
you know go make content that's what
it's about
would you say you're asking for less
money these days when you approach an
investor absolutely i mean you know
the the go-to for everybody i think that
is pitching an investor
is well there's so much
so much opportunity for for distribution
now well there might be but what does it
pay
you know the home video market is done
that was really the biggest revenue that
we were seeing on our independent films
when when blockbuster and hollywood
video was out and before the netflix
world
the money that us indy folks saw was was
pretty substantial on the returns that's
not happening anymore so you're
streaming you're seeing sometimes
pennies pennies for streams
and aod and vods where before you were
seeing dollars
so
what we try to do is we we've got it
figured out how to make films on a dime
and make them at least the production
value is good
so what we do is we present a product
that is
marketable it looks good it fits with
everything else that's happening that we
were able to produce for a fraction of
the cost of what everybody else is
making it for which
when it sells the deals are smaller but
the investors are still happy because
the risk was low the rewards are what
they are but it all it all comes
parallel what's happened is
the budgets you know for the films that
we do at like 500 650 000
when home video was around that was gold
but because everything's streaming now
for the most part you may get a few tv
deals that pay okay but you don't want
to count on those those are those are
like you know easter eggs are great when
you find them
but you want to keep your investors
happy you know money out money in
and the returns on those are not only
lower they also take forever to pay
these streaming deals you know when you
work with a distributor they usually
have 90 days after the previous quarter
to pay well they're still dealing with
the same thing at their end from the
streaming platforms so the streaming
platforms could take 90 to 120 days to
report and pay them and then they have
another 90 days after the quarter to pay
you
so you could be looking at eight nine
months before you see a dime on a stream
so these are things that you have to be
very upfront about with your investors
you have to let them know that this is
this is the way it is now
um you know the misnomer is that there's
so many you know big dollar deals for
everybody you hear and read about the
big dollar deals that's that's what
keeps the wheels turning but the
majority
is you're dealing with smaller deals and
i really encourage filmmakers to try to
keep their their budgets
lower so they can get more content made
you can really learn how this industry
is working if you're not working at the
studio system
what would you say is the sweet spot
that an independent filmmaker should
spend on their movie i think a sweet
spot for an independent filmmaker is
it's different for everybody because
content different content drives more
dollars internationally you know comedy
if it's circumstantial comedy that's one
thing but if it's it's written comedy it
doesn't always translate foreign so
you're limiting your foreign
certain films don't do well overseas so
i don't think there's a sweet spot for
everybody i think there are sweet spots
that people can do
and if you're going to spend more money
just put it in the cast it really is
it's if there's content there's content
that fits a niche or a genre but then
there's also star power and if you're
trying to get a-list actors they're
always going to cost you a lot of money
so you know some independent filmmakers
do very well they'll make three or four
million dollar films they'll put two
million dollars into two actors and then
everything else is you know the rest of
the film there's nothing wrong with that
um
if you're doing you know the walk and
talk dramas i you know unless you're
you're knocking it out of the park with
star power why do these films need to be
made for more than three hundred
thousand dollars i just i don't know why
they would need to be if you're not if
you are not justifying it with the star
power
again
spend 10 million if you're getting
george clooney and meg ryan or whoever's
hot today you know it changes every
other day
that's justifiable globally that's going
to do a lot for your revenue but if
you're working with
actors that are really good at their
craft that that are blue collar actors
that are going to get the job done but
they're not marquee
you know you really got to think about
how you can keep the costs down because
again the less you spend the less you're
going to make especially when it comes
to talent
but
again you have to navigate what it is
you're selling if you're selling action
you know what are the star power that
you need to pull the action film or is
it going to do good globally besides
here in north america
horror does that translate worldwide
does you know
psychological thrillers do well you know
every film genre has its goods and bads
all over the globe and you really need
to research that before you find your
sweet spot and we find our sweet spot
just by trial and error i mean you know
we haven't we haven't hit home runs
every time we make a movie you know base
hits and doubles are wonderful but you
really you really need to understand the
playing field before you find your sweet
spot you know and i think it's different
for every every genre and it's different
for every filmmaker too